hi i'm here with one of the stars of
vacation friends meredith hagner
that's embarrassing i'm like i know
right um well something that you're into
though is my biggest passion and i
actually want to become your student
right now you're going to take over the
show and lead me through your process
and teach us all a few things i feel
like we're chip and joanna but we're but
i think we're both chip
i'll be anything you pick and i'll be
the other one
okay uh i'll
let's just both be chip okay great okay
two chips two chips is better than one
all right um when you're shopping online
it can get intimidating i now do a lot
of online shopping because as thrifters
yeah you would have to go to the actual
places and i still do but there's new
online opportunities like never before
yeah so like when you're looking online
what are your tips i feel like i like to
get a sense i feel like you can learn
pretty quickly if someone's crazy on
email and
i like to look at the photo and then
kind of peek behind to see if
something's really disgusting and be
like i'm going to pass upholstery just
don't go there because there's a 98
chance you will infect your guests with
bed bugs
and so yeah i like to just get an email
sent i always bring a friend because you
just don't know what you're walking into
do you ever like haggle oh all the time
yeah big haggler but do it on email
because you don't want to be there with
someone like someone dog growling at you
like how much no you know just don't i
just tackled my way like uh i just i'm
surprising ross with his new dressing
room today
um and i fully designed it and i went
into the store and i haggled the guy
down and it just it feels so good i'm so
like i know they're looking at me like i
know who you you know just
i know
i know they're looking at me like oh no
you are not acting like me but i'm like
i am a lifelong thrifter and that is
part of the gig
don't you feel powerful when you haggle
all right we're gonna go over to a
little setup and chip you're gonna take
us through it okay chip all right chip
all right chip so
excited
um
so your show really helped with this
obviously but it's pretty incredible so
a fun thing to do yes is take like get
vintage fabrics yeah really easy to turn
it into like a little pillow like this
this is all vintage fabric from
craigslist and then also you can do i'll
use it either as like a tablecloth
sometimes a little runner yep a little
runner action yeah like a nice little
sort of burlappy thing can add a lot of
texture as you see this table is sort of
like threaded and glossy but the overlap
changes that it calms it down okay um
what's the next item okay next item is a
lamp see this lamp yes it was like 20
bucks it was very dated
and
um it was a kind of lamp where you'd be
and you'd be like ew why would anyone
put this in their house but paint it
white and then change the lampshade you
can either do like a black matte thing
which goes with this vibe or you could
do something kind of colorful and you
know really impressive and i really love
that shade it's giving me like that
dome shape imagine this at night like
all moody i i i love this okay uh what's
the last item this side table so this
was like a 20
20
yes
this is the thing if you're not the
handiest just enlist someone in your
life to do manual labor for you for free
but you take the legs off and you take
these cylinders from home depot chop
them up
glue them to the it sounds really this
is and people are like what no no
meredith like i'm i'm literally freaking
out right now you don't even understand
here's why
if you show the before picture
you've changed the actual architecture
of the table instead of the legs being
at the corner yeah you've inset them
yeah and that actually will give you
more depth exactly that is really
impressive
thanks okay i
god i mean you are just
you are
everything and more i love you i am
inspired i you know you're my chip
you're my chip
i'm going to see you out and be like
oh everybody thank you meredith hagner
and peter
to
watch vacation friends
and then
if you want to know what all the cool
kids are watching
and you want to be super on point you
watch search party all right and that'll
be available on hbo max meredith chip
chimp we'll be right back
[Music]
you